die einsatzleitzentrale am flughafen ist
zuständig für alle möglichen notfälle
von 18 millionen menschen
das epizentrum der kunst ist aktuell die
biennale von venedig und sie ist alle
zwei jahre zuständig für das große
schaulaufen von kunstschaffenden aus
aller welt
doch diese biennale will mehr sie will
uns konfrontieren mit dem elend das
flüchtlingsströme oder entfesselt der
kapitalmärkte auslösen
der parcours durch die biennale trägt
also nicht nur zu einem eisgekühlten bei
linie an sondern auch zum nachdenken
eine kleine kirche im historischen
zentrum von venedig scheinbar idyllische
kirche santa maria della misericordia
seit 45 jahren steht sie leer
doch seit einer woche birgt zündstoff
der schweizer künstler christoph büchel
hat aus der ehemaligen kirche mit
gezielten eingriffen eine moschee
gemacht eine ganze eine gebetsnische
eine gebets uhr alles korrekt nach mekka
ausgerichtet
das kunstprojekt ist die erste moschee
überhaupt in der lagunenstadt mit ihren
20.000 in venedig und umgebung lebende
muslime ein umstrittener eingriff in die
stadt der kirchen und palazzi die
behörden drohen jetzt schon sie zu
schließen
kunst die sich politisch einmischen
darum geht's an der diesjährigen
biennale in venedig auch wenn man sich
immer wieder die frage stellen muss
kann kunst krisen kommentieren oder kann
sie einfach nur abbilden
der künstler als zuschauer jedenfalls
hat ausgedient
kurator okwui enwezor nigerianer mit us
pass hat ein händchen für brisante
themen
er verantwortet dieses jahr die
hauptausstellung und beginnt mit einem
klaren statement floss blut
brooms floss blut und prellungen
ein zitat aus den rassenunruhen der 60er
jahre in den usa
damals wie heute geht es um
polizeigewalt gegen schwarze kunst als
pointierter kommentar zu den aktuellen
unruhen in baltimore
es gibt kunstwerke die nicht darauf
basierend laut zuspricht